[Music]
the wealthy world is aging
fast
in 1950 around 1 in every 12 people in
high income countries was over 65.
by 2050 it's expected to be more like
one in four
and it's storing up a big problem
it is a feat that we can live longer and
that we can enjoy
being alive for longer but it's
expensive
when people retire they start to cost
society more money
and the costs will soon be unsustainable
what's becoming increasingly clear is
that the three stage model of life where
you educate your work you retire is
fundamentally broken
current approaches to care for the
elderly are a massive drain on society's
resources
if you look at it from an economical
perspective
we are spending too much money
on doing the wrong things
and these mistakes cost more than just
money i don't feel that the older
population are valued i think
we may be an inconvenience
so how can societies provide high
quality but affordable care for their
growing elderly populations
both today and into the future
yamakita japan
news crews have been sent to cover the
final graduation ceremony at miho
elementary school
what makes this national news is that 12
year old reiki kodama is the only people
in his year group
the 146 year old school will close after
reiki's graduation
the town's population has dropped by
around 30 percent over the past three
decades
and there simply aren't enough pupils to
keep the school open
japan is the oldest nation on earth
with the highest proportion of elderly
people in its population
the changing shape of societies in the
developed world is clearly shown by un
population data
in 1950 there were more than double the
number of people in their 20s compared
with those in their 60s
but today the number in their 60s has
nearly tripled
the number of children and retirees
relative to those of working age is
known as the dependency ratio
when this changes it can mean there are
fewer workers to support the elderly
which has serious economic consequences
an aging population of course brings
lots of uh good and exciting things but
it's expensive the cost of pensions the
cost of health care which is largely
spent on people in their last years of
life it's very costly
when people retire in their 60s they
tend to spend less
pay less in taxes
and cost society more
a shrinking workforce can also cause gdp
growth and investment to slow
which threatens economic stagnation
some countries such as france have made
repeated attempts to shake up their
pension systems including by raising the
retirement age
but this has led to fierce protests
[Music]
there are other ways to reduce the
dependency ratio such as encouraging
immigration of skilled workers and
improving child care provision to
encourage more women to work
but these aren't enough
a lot of this is about tweaking around
the edges and if you really think of the
magnitude of the challenge here the more
fruitful thinking lies in a really quite
a fundamental shift in how we think
about different life stages
many people are already challenging
these traditional attitudes to aging
at an age when most would be thinking
about retiring 68 year old julie ford
has reinvented herself as an
entrepreneur
hi bridge hi nichola how you doing i've
been involved in health and fitness and
i'm a pe teacher of 45 years yes let's
get out in that fresh area and then i
was diagnosed with breast cancer
and i was physically still fit
two very important things smiling and
breathing if you can only do one at a
time can you just please breathe
julie designed and built a training aid
called instep and runs workout classes
using it resistance training is the best
for strength scientifically proven
that moving
with resistance is the golden ticket of
exercise
julie is part of an online community
called rest less
which helps retirees who want to keep
working
it was set up by stuart lewis
everything we do is tailored to this
demographic of people in the 50s 60s and
beyond
there's a wide range of life needs that
people have and we're trying to meet
them across health
community and social networking
offering advice on jobs pensions further
education and even dating
restless helps people navigate one of
the biggest transitions they will face
in their lifetimes
you've worked 45 years 50 years of your
life and suddenly
you stop well what do you do it is very
difficult
you just need to look at the impact of
someone who's been out of work for two
years to see the impact on their
physical health but also their mental
health it's the same when you're into
retirement for some people it can be
quite a lonely and desolate time
but extending their working life might
not be practical for everyone
people don't all experience aging in the
same way and that's a really important
thing to to keep in mind i mean a
starting point is of course what kind of
job you did all your life well not
everyone can work until they're 90.
that still doesn't take away the fact
that in the rich world 90 of people will
now reach their 65th birthday and most
of them will still have plenty of
healthy years ahead of them
encouraging people to make use of these
healthy years could unlock economic
potential that's being lost in
retirement to make the most of this
increasing life expectancy to reap the
so-called longevity dividend you do need
to make sure that you set the
infrastructure up to make that possible
more flexible
ways of tapping into say your pension
savings to employers taking a more
open-minded approach
so we're invaluable in society and i
think we should be used or made use of
more flexible attitudes to retirement
could help reduce the economic burden of
increasingly elderly populations
but eventually most people will need
some form of medical or social care and
that
is expensive
a lot of countries just haven't really
grappled with the need to set up a
decent social care system
social care used to happen a lot in the
family sort of it used to be informally
covered as we would call it there were
always carers but they were just unpaid
carers
it's daunting because there are an awful
lot of people that will need it and it's
a labor-intensive thing to do
in many developed countries when people
can no longer care for themselves a
typical answer is to move them out of
their homes and communities into
residential care
but as well as being increasingly
unaffordable this model of care can fail
to address the emotional needs of
elderly people
the rich world have taken a fairly
reactive approach to to care for the
elderly the traditional approach has
been essentially warehousing people in
nursing homes
the metrics of success have often been
things like has a person had any falls
have they lost any weight or did they
have any bed sores and because they
became the important metrics the
institutions started operating around
those things i think what's got lost in
social care is a more community focused
approach
[Music]
in the netherlands an organization
called bertzorg is re-establishing this
community approach to care
ramona vanden arendt is a burtzorg nurse
working in ada
[Music]
today she has three male patients to
visit all with complex needs
central to bert talks method is using
local nursing teams who know the
community and who are given real
autonomy in managing their workload
you work together as a group as a team
and together you
discuss what kind of tasks everybody
takes in the team
one of her patients today is 82 year old
mr vandermeen who suffers pain from
cancer in his ear
managing her own timetable means ramona
can give him the special care he needs
to stay living safely in his own home
in healthcare it's always changing how
many clients you have what is needed how
much time we need to spend at the
clients
so it's necessary that we can take
decisions ourselves
bert's org was set up by yoster block
who had himself been a community nurse
for nearly a decade
so my idea was we just start
from scratch
and we just ask nurses to do
what i think they should do
not on protocols not on products look at
a problem and try to solve the problem
in the most effective way
the other key part of burt talks
philosophy is setting aside time to talk
to the patient and build a deeper
understanding of their needs and
aspirations
i think the most important thing that
when you come at the client's house
it's important to listen that you take
the time to
hear somebody's story
it might seem inevitable that spending
extra time with patients would drive up
costs but in bert talks case the
opposite is true
if we trust people and we ask them
to do what they think is needed then we
use the capacity more effectively than
we're doing
now separate studies by ernst and young
and kpmg found that burt's org delivered
over 30 cost and 50 time savings
compared with existing dutch care
systems
in a sector known for high staff
turnover it now employs over 10 000
nurses in the netherlands and is
operating in 30 countries
as well as being efficient giving nurses
independence also protects the
independence of those in their care
aging populations threaten societies
with shrinking workforces
economic stagnation
and crippling costs for pensions and
care
simply throwing more money at the issue
is not going to be enough
from a societal perspective i think
we're missing the huge opportunity we
have to help people age better to live
better lives dealing with aging is a
opportunity but also a problem that
keeps getting kicked down the road
we can't just keep postponing actually
dealing with it or wishfully thinking
that tweaking around the edges around
the retirement age will fix it needs a
much much bigger more fundamental
rethink
i'm tom standage deputy editor of the
economist and editor of the world ahead
to read more of our future gazing
coverage click on the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]